desde hace varios días aquí en israel la
pregunta no era si la coalición iba a
caer sino cuándo ocurriría y eso se
terminó definiendo en esta jornada con
la reunión entre natalie y seguirla pitt
quienes optaron por la disolución del
parlamento en la razón principal y el
punto de no retorno ha sido el bloqueo
que se ocurrió en la que es el de la ley
sobre para los asentamientos judíos que
básicamente es una serie de normas de
emergencia que se renuevan cada cinco
años y que permiten que la ley civil
israelí sea aplicada a los colonos
judíos en territorios ocupados de
cisjordania esta ley fue
sistemáticamente bloqueada por la
oposición pese a que amplios sectores de
la derecha están de acuerdo con estas
normativas y el gobierno en minoría en
el parlamento por la deserción de 13 de
sus integrantes no ha podido sacar
adelante esta normativa fue eso en
propias palabras de benet hace unos
minutos en lo que terminó empujando al
gobierno a decidir su disolución y optar
por una convocatoria a nuevas elecciones
que permite que automáticamente éstas de
emergencia se renueven y que de esta
manera terminé haciendo esta alianza
bennett defendió igualmente en su breve
discurso que se trató de un buen
gobierno pero que la disolución de este
ejecutivo es la decisión correcta
federico y que éste puede esperar
brevemente de cara a las elecciones
por calendario las elecciones se podrían
llevar a cabo recién a finales de
octubre una vez transcurrido el periodo
de vacaciones y uno de los que celebro
la caída de este gobierno fue el ex
primer ministro benjamin netanyahu quien
lo calificó como el peor gobierno de la
historia su partido likud es el que
lidera las encuestas y su posible
retorno al poder tampoco está tan claro
porque es una figura que genera
divisiones por ejemplo el actual
ministro de justicia aquí de gonzar ya
salió a decir que los próximos comicios
serán para evitar el regreso de
netanyahu ven lo inmediato por ejemplo
el presidente
estadounidense joe biden ahora será
recibido por la pide en su gira por
medio oriente el 3 del 13 al 16 de julio